اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المسافه ثلاث
ملفات وهذه هي العناوين
السعوديه تتسلم رئاسه اعمال القمه العربيه
ثانيه وثلاثين وسط ترحيب عربي بعوده سوريا
لمقعدها بالجامعه كيف ستعيد قمه جده بلوره
اليه العمل العربي المشترك في ظل التحديات
الاقليميه والدوليه
قرر مجلس النواب
ايقاف السيد رئيس الحكومه سيد فتحي باش
اغا واحالته للتحقيق
ايقافوا رئيس الحكومه الليبيه فتحي باشاغه
والتحقيق معه يربك ليبيا التي تقف على
ابواب الانتخابات هل للقرار البرلماني
خلفيه سياسيه ام ان فشل بشاغه في الالتزام
بتعهداته تسبب في ايقافه
هي تستفيد من المنظومه الفرنسيه
مثلا في التمويل العامه
ثلاث نقاش ثالث فرنسا تحاصر تمويل جماعه
الاخوان وتجمد 25 مليون يورو جمعتها
الجامعه من التبرعات او الجماعات هل حدث
تهاون في مراقبه صناديق التبرعات ولماذا
ام ان المراقبه تحد ويصعب
تنظيم مساراته
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى نقاش الاول لاجل عمل عربي
مشترك لرفعه الشعوب العربيه تنعقد القمه
العربيه ثانيه وثلاثون في مدينه جده
السعوديه يوم الجمعه المقبل تحديات قديمه
وجديده وتطلعات لتحقيق نتائج مهمه على
مستويات عده قمه جده وصفت بانها قمه
التغيير والتجديد وبانها قمه البدايه
الجديده فهي تنعقد بعد تحركات دبلوماسيه
عده للتقارب وفي ظل اجواء ايجابيه غير
مسبوقه على صعيد المنطقه العربيه منذ
سنوات طويله خاصه انها تنعقد بمشاركه
سوريا بعد 12 عاما من الغياب حيث ستكون
قضيه اعاده اعمار سوريا من ابرز ملفات هذه
القناه السفير حسام زكي مساعد الامين
العام للجامعه العربيه قال ان الملف
السوداني كذلك سيتصدر ابرز الملفات
المنتظره على طويله القاده العرب كما لفت
السفير الى ان هناك ملفات سياسيه مهمه
اخرى تاتي في مقدمتها القضيه الفلسطينيه
اضافه الى الاتفاق السعودي الايراني الذي
تنتظر انعكاساته على الاستقرار في المنطقه
قمم عربيه في السعوديه
اكتوبر من عام
قمه الرياض الطارئه بدعوه من السعوديه
والكويت وبمشاركه كل من مصر وسوريا ولبنان
ومنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
مارس من عام 2007 القمه العربيه العاديه
التاسعه عشره عقدت بالرياض بحضور 17 زعيما
عربيا ونتجت عنها قرارات تخص القضيه
الفلسطينيه والعراق
ابريل من عام 2018
القمه العربيه العاديه التاسعه والعشرون
عقدت في الظهران واعلنت السعوديه خلالها
تبرعها ب 200 مليون دولار لفلسطين
مايو من عام 2019
قمه مكه المكرمه لاستثنائيه بحثت التحديات
التي تمر بها المنطقه
وتداعياتها على الامن والسلم الاقليمي
والدوري
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من الرياض جسر
الجسر الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك ومن القاهره
الدكتور جمال عبد الجواد مستشار ومركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من الرياض معك استاذ جاسر استاذ جاسر حتى
نتكلم بكل موضوعيه تعلم حضرتك بانه القمه
العربيه السابقه شهدت سنوات لم تتمكن من
ان
تنتج عنها مخرجات حقيقيه او فعليه او على
الاقل مخرجات تفسر لنا وتفهمنا كيف هي
العلاقات اولا العربيه العربيه
ومالات ما تم بحثه ولكن هذه القمه يقول
البعض بانها استثنائيه لان الاجواء اساسا
تشهد تطورات فخلينا نفهم مع حضرتك قراءتك
لانعقاد هذه القناه بالتحديد وما الجديد
الذي قد تقراه في خصوص مخرجات هذه القمه
مساء الخير ريم مساء الخير دكتور جمال
ايضا طبعا نتفق اولا لماذا تنعقد القمه
الان بعد سته شهور من قمه الجزائر هناك
اشياء حدثت على الارض لم تكن سابق لا يمكن
للمره الاولى تنعقد القمه العربيه وهناك
مكتسبات او اجراءات تحدث على الارض نحن
شهدنا الاتفاق السعودي الايراني الاجتماع
الاطراف السودانيه في جده حرحله الملف
اليمني عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
كمؤشرات اوليه واساسيه اذا هناك
نيه رغبه واضحه في عمل حقيقي لا يحتمل
الانتظار لن ننتظر سنه كامله لتنعقد القمه
وهناك تحضيرات ايضا على الارض في الواقع
في التواصل والتنسيق يعني شاهدنا في
اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه والقاهره مثلا لجنه
التواصل بخصوص سوريا لجنه التواصل بخصوص
السودان هذه نمط عمل جديد لذلك اليوم هذه
القمه تختلف عن اي قمه سابقه في انها
اعتقد فعلا يعني وفق هذه المعطيات وفق هذه
المقاومات والرغبه وطريقه العمل وما يحدث
الارض والحراك الدبلوم والترتيبات المسبقه
بشكل مكثف لانجاحها انها فعلا خطه عمل
يعني اعتقد الجامعه العربيه اليوم يوم
الجمعه لن تكون الجامعه العربيه قبل يوم
الجمعه سيكون صفحه اخرى وسيكون هناك فريق
عمل يتابع وينفذ ويحقق خطط عمل ليس مجرد
بيان ليس مجرد توافق اذا الترتيبات لهذه
القمه قامت على افكار ومخططات وبرامج ولم
تقم فقط على مجرد تصور ليست مجرد حشد عربي
هي فعلا تغيير تجديد عامل عربي مشترك لما
الشمل كل هذه العبارات جميله نسمعها طبعا
سنواجه بعض الصعوبات لكن في المعطى
الاساسي مستمر الامور في النجاح اعاده
سوريا والعمل على اعمارها واستقرارها وهذا
سينعكس على البيئه المحيط العراق والاردن
ولبنان العمل ايضا على استقرار السودان
اعاده السلام والاستقرار اليمن بجمع
الاطراف اليمنيه وحوارها اللغه اختلفت
يعني ولا الفريق العربي اختلف ونلاحظ ايضا
انه كان هناك تنسيق سعودي جزائري بخصوص
الاعتبار الرئيسي القمه وايضا تنسيق سعودي
باعتبارها مسرار يعني الامين العام ومقر
الجامعه العربيه انا اعتقد انك روح عمل
مختلفه تقوم على الخطوات والامير فيصل قال
نحن نواجه تحديات مهمه تحتاج الى تكتيكات
جديده اذا احنا نتكلم على خطه عمل لاختلف
للمره الاولى تكاد تشابه قمه العشرين في
فرق العمل وتواصل الى القمه المقبله وليس
فقط بيان ويصدر ثم ينفض الجمع وتعود
الامور الى ما كانت عليه تحديات سنتحدث
معك دكتور جمال دكتور جمال بما رشح من
تصريحات سبقت هذه القمه وكذلك من مواقف
ومن عمل دبلوماسي مستمر في الواقع
قادته مجموعه من الدول العربيه ماذا في
تحديات هذه القمه ماذا في الاولويات خاصه
التحدي الاهم هو تحويل الممكنات اللي
اصبحت متاحه وما كانتش متاحه قبل كده الى
واقع هناك كما يمكن اعتبارها توقعات
متزايده بشان هذه القمه بسبب التحركات
الكبيره اللي سبقتها على عده جبهات في
المنطقه واللي كانت المملكه السعوديه في
الحقيقه في مركزها فانت تنعقد القمه في في
العاصمه في السعوديه التي قادت عدد من
التحركات المهمه في المنطقه السابعه اطلقت
توقعات كبيره تحويل هذه التوقعات الى
حقيقه والى واقع في الفتره المقبله خلق
اليه للمتابعه
التحوي تحويل قرارات القمه العربيه الى
شيء فعلا يؤثر في مصالح الدول اعضاء
الجامعه وربما في المواطنين اللي بيعيشوا
في هذه الدول هذا هو التحدي الاهم اللي
بتواجهوا هذه القمه في الحقيقه تحدي
الفاعليه وما بعد القمه وليس القمه في حد
ذاتها لتكتمل هذه الفكره استاذ جاسر
ولتكون هناك
فعاليه حقيقيه لتحقيق ما اتفق عليه خلال
هذه القمه ما الذي يجب ان يتوفر على
المستوى الدبلوماسي ولكن حتى على مستوى
تقارب وجهات النظر بين مختلف الدول
التنميه والاستقرار عوامل اساسيه لاننا
نتكلم على العمل الدبلوماسي هو تقريب
وجهات النظر لكن هناك عمل تنموي يجب ان
تشترك في الدول العربيه وهذا ما يحدث هذا
ما نشهده اليوم في الصلات الاقتصاديه بين
الدول العربيه وخصوصا بين الدول الخليجيه
والاردن ومصر
والعراق بشكل اساسي وايضا الجزائر هناك
عمل نحن نختلف اليوم ان الخطاب ليس مجرد
خطاب سياسي ليس مجرد لغه هناك حركه عمل
وهذا جديد في الثقافه العربيه الثقافه
العربيه بطبيعتها خطابيا ذات نبره عاليه
وليست اليات عمل نحن اليوم محتاجين لاليات
عمل تعمل الجامعه العربيه كمؤسسه تنفيذيه
تتمنى القرارات وتعمل على اساسها مدى
النجاحات تختلف لكن لنقل بشكل واضح سيكون
هناك اعمار كامل وحقيقي لسوريا لتحقيق
الاستقرار فيها والعمل
الدكتور فيصل مقداد انه الاتفاق مع
السعوديه تم نلتقي مع الامير فيصل انه نحن
اتفقنا على اعاده المستوى والعمل المشترك
هذاك عمل شكل فرق عمل تعمل على اساس الدعم
الاقتصادات العربيه التنميه نحن نتكلم على
مشروع انه يكون هناك تنميه عربيه واستقرار
عربي ولنشهد انه حتى الخطاب السياسي في
اختلف اصبح رويه تنمويه وليس خطاب يعني
على قائمه الاسس والقواعد والعمل
الاقتصاديه والتنميه والحاجه الادراك هناك
ادراك داخلي في المنظومه العربيه تزين مو
كليا صحيح في صعوبات في تحديات في مشاكل
لكن سنحقق او ستحقق الجامعه العربيه نجحت
معقوله ليس مئه في الميه قد تتعثر بعض
الامور وسيكون هناك تطلعات المستقبل
تطلعات في تحسين الاستقرار في السودان حل
الملف الليبي عكس ان المساله ليست قائمه
على قمه نحن اليوم نتكلم ناكد على نقطه
هذه القمه هي فريق عمل يتشكل الى عقد
القمه المقبله في البحرين ويعمل هذا
بالتواصل والمشاريع الاقتصاديه واللقاءات
الاقتصاديه واللقاءات الدبلوماسيه
واختخيار الجميع ونقل الملفات العربيه
ايضا المجتمع الدولي بما فيها الملف
السوري هل حالات الملف السوري من قبل
العلاقات الدوليه لتحقيق التنميه اذا
مشروع كامل
الالتزام بها واليوم نسمع على اعاده اعمار
سوريا هل تعتقد بانه الجامعه العربيه او
هذه القمه هذه المره كذلك تقدمت بخطوه
اخرى ايجابيه تجاه سوريا لمحاوله على
الاقل ايجاد حلول وسط بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا لمحاوله البناء فيما بعد
جدا بالتاكيد التصور انه
التشجيع الكافي والمكافاه تم وضعها على
المائده لصنع القرار السوري انه
المصالحه السياسيه الاصلاح السياسي
استيعاب المعارضه حل مشكله
اللاجئين والنازحين كل هذا هو عنصر ضروري
ومكافئته واضحه المساهمه الفعاله في اعاده
الاعمار لم يعد الكلام مجرد وعد او
مشروطيه كما كان الحال سابقا الان الدول
العربيه والجامعه العربيه
اعادت لسوريا مقعدها في الجامعه
وتعاملت معها بشكل بشكل كامل بنديه كامله
هذا يبين ان هناك جديه كامله من الدول
العربيه في التعاطي مع الوضع السوري اتصور
انه الكره الان في الملعب السوري وانا لا
احب استخدم تعبير الكره اتمنى انه يكون
هناك صيغ تعاونيه اكثر منها صيغ التبا
التقاذف الكره كما كان الحال في فتره
سابقه اتصور انه الحكومه في سوريا والنظام
في سوريا جاهز للتعاطي بطريقه مختلفه وده
اللي سهل الوصول الى هذه النقطه نعم على
كل كانت هذه مصافحه اولى في الواقع غدا
سنتحدث اكثر وسنناقش اكثر ملف قمه جده
ساكتفي معكم بهذا القدر شكرا جزيلا على
المشاركه من الرياض جسر الجسر الكاتب
الصحفي ومن القاهره الدكتور جمال عبد
الجواد مستشار مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات